- [Narrator] What do you
get when you put together
rubber gloves, rain boots, LED lights,
and a cake saver?
You get a hitchhiking robot?
- [Robot] Hello.
Would you like to have a conversation?
(happy symphonic music)
- [Narrator] Meet Dr. Frauke Zeller,
and David Harris Smith.
- Hello.
- [Narrator] They're the
creators of hitchBOT.
- [hitchBOT] My name is hitchBOT.
- [Narrator] Which is?
- [Dr. Zeller] hitchBOT
is a hitchhiking robot,
that hitchhikes around the country.
And is dependent on the help of strangers.
- [Narrator] So this
DIY robot had a mission.
To hitchhike across Canada.
From Halifax all the way to Victoria.
- [Dr. Zeller] We wanted
people to help the robot
to really see in the project, how far
will people go, not just
take a robot in the car,
but also helping it.
(white noise)
- [Narrator] Usually it's
humans who are scared
that robots will take over the world.
(crashing of metal)
(ominous music, screaming and sparking)
Well, these guys flipped
that idea on its head.
- [Dr. Zeller] The main question was,
can robots trust humans?
- [Narrator] And with
one thumb in the air,
the international sign
for lemme hitch a ride,
hitchBOT started its
journey across Canada.
It quickly captured hearts and minds,
in Canada and beyond.
- We heard from many people that they
would start their day with a cup of coffee
and opening up the hitchBOT website,
to see where it had been on the map.
hitchBOT was getting the
kind of quintessential
Canadian experience by
heading off for a camping
trip in the Gaspe Peninsula.
It had ferry rides,
it went to a First Nations pow wow.
Really, kind of diverse
cultural experience,
that really spanned the country.
- [Narrator] It took
hitchBOT under a month,
and a dozen-and-a-half helpers
to travel 3800 miles across Canada.
- I had just recently moved to Canada
when we started the project.
I was taken aback by how
helpful and enthusiastic
they were about this
little robot basically.
Was wonderful to see the community spirit
that was built.
- [Narrator] And that's
the story of how one robot
hitchhiked across Canada.